foreign
so uh I don't know if some of you guys
might have heard of this a news anchor
was recently taken off air I believe
even fired for quoting Snoop Dogg during
a live broadcast oh I heard about this
you'd have to quote a pretty specific
part was it was it [__] ain't hoes
butt holes and tricks that one [__]
ain't [__] [__] ain't [__] but a hole
no fun what was he saying all that stuff
I can't I won't guess no okay
undercover cops okay because because the
earlier albums really can get you in
some trouble which one is it which one
is it no it's got to be something that
seemingly you wouldn't think is like
that bad so because a news anchor would
say it
but it means something else yeah
oh we're just doing a live TV broadcast
think about Snoop just really boil it
Down Right brand wise okay when you
think about Snoop Dogg yeah what do you
always hear him say counting one two
even like 10 years ago
about three for shizzle my nizzle
oh you can't say you know what he said
yeah you can't say nizzle why do you
can't why do you can't why do you can't
yeah
you can't say the rest of that because I
think that's supposed to be my
n-word in an endearing way yeah
and we're gonna endearing but nizzle
rhymes with sizzle
true I think on this
um you know it rhymes with chisel news
proper and respected news show for some
reason we can yeah but on NBC's
affiliate WLBT on on you know actual TV
you can't say especially if you're not
even the word white lady uh who has been
working there for like 20 years I know
she's like come on man years for that
mistake I think it's even
if it's an old white lady saying it
pretty good I agree but then it's almost
as if like a white lady got taken off
the air for saying N word like literally
n and then w-o-r-d you're one of my
favorite scenes I didn't say the word I
literally said the theme yeah I said the
substitute word I'm in trouble what the
[__] because I guess you are yeah
there's actually a good scene and scary
movie the opening scene when that
Grandma is singing mystical on the piano
herself you know and shake that ass
watch yourself and then she sings the
whole thing says the n-word everything
everybody's dying and laughing and it's
it's all good because what it was the
Wayne brothers creators who wrote that
script and they thought of that scene a
white grandma singing it was hilarious
it is hilarious
yeah I mean it was a long time ago too I
mean this is very different from that I
mean Leonardo DiCaprio did it we all
know it's okay because Quentin Tarantino
wrote it
that's true oh yeah he did say quite a
bit of that movie he kind of says it a
lot in lots of movies
a lot though huh what other movies so
much so much he gets it in most of his
movies all of them I wonder how Jamie
Foxx felt about it
I think he's I think he's okay with it I
think he did an impression of Quentin
telling him that
didn't he yeah it was like Quentin too
do you think he read the script and said
he's so talented yeah historical
entertainment context when it was like
not appropriate but like used verbiage
during that time does it like fall under
some sort of like okay well you know
what I mean it's in this context
no not this concert like a Leonardo
DiCaprio but they're trying to they're
trying to paint a picture and it's a
time and it's it's a the theme I think
it should be okay how come literature
from those actual times they're scrubs
yeah they're being like people are weird
all those they're kicking they're taking
them out because they can still be
edited in a lot of ways you can't edit
this might be a Nick question
but did Snoop comment on this
he did not comment on this but uh you
know who did comment on it was
Charlemagne on The Breakfast Club what
do you say he actually said I don't
think she should have been fired for
that she might not have even known what
nizzle means yo come on like Karen
that's not a reason to fire that woman
show her
Charlemagne's so good because sometimes
I agree the [__] out of him as soon as I
want to slap him in the face do you
think she got do you think she got fired
by a white boss she looks like Alice
from The Brady Bunch dude
I mean they look like they could be
friends she looked like she just got
fired right there after Snoop Dogg
started hanging out with Martha Stewart
I just feel like all middle-aged white
ladies are his best friends how did she
say it though did she say like that she
like turn her cap backwards all of a
sudden and like
she was like yeah a little bit too
leaning into it a little bit she's
having too much fun yeah or was she like
quoting
and I quote for shizzle my nizzle from
Snoop Dogg I don't think she was quoting
but I don't know I'm not sure
it's probably one of the most funniest
moments in just regular TV
having something like do you have a
video of it yeah yeah a person saying
stuff like
and it's old the reference is old it's
not even new like people aren't saying
that [__] right now Morning News is the
worst here we go
Lane they all think they're so funny
come up with I think that'd be pretty
cool well we know what she'd have a
Snoop Dogg tattoo on her shoulder a
shizzle my nizzle I'm telling you Julie
what you think about it see the
referencing stuff
he said huh she said it
so you think that guy ruined it he might
have
because you know in a room like what no
that means she's [__] cool like she
understood she said Snoop Dogg without
skipping a beat what did he want her to
say it ain't no fun if the homies can't
have none that would have been cool she
probably would have but then that
sensitive ass [__] I think is
the one that got on fire because you
know like in this room someone can say
something crazy but if we all got his
back it's cool but he was the one that's
like everyone knows like oh my god oh he
made it serious he didn't have the
homies back he felt that one he really
don't like her though maybe she's like
kind of a dick to him or something oh
yeah maybe she did in that type of
conscience now that we see that like
that it's like that's definitely like
not the right thing to say no it's not
yeah really the other guy referenced it
and she's just letting him know like hey
I understand I think in this day morning
banter yeah there's argument to get her
in trouble there's there's more than her
that's [__] up in his day and age yeah
if this happened freaking five years ago
I don't think anyone bad night
I think she could have been Sable I
don't think anybody wanted to do it yeah
hey [__] next what a bus though since
she's been working there for like 20
years like that's gotta like stand for
something you know what I mean like I
don't think she should have been even
the Loyalty of like the radio show being
like you know maybe we like apologize
well what's weird to me not necessarily
like let's fire her but morning what's
weird to me though is she's a fan like
when someone references Snoop Dogg and
you say that you're a fan you get the
reference you understand the music right
it's not like I don't I don't get it
it's not like racism yeah if she was a
fan though I think there are better
lines to say as well I think morning you
can pick a different line but I don't
think she I think who said it I don't
think she even knows what the [__] it
means like it's like a slogan yeah she
probably doesn't know what I mean yeah
that is synonymous with Snoop Dogg it's
100 synonymous and honestly I didn't
even think about it until we brought it
up today you're like oh yeah that is
referring and when rap artists or
hip-hop artists or anything like that
have the n-bomb in their songs it's uh
it's censored on the radio whereas that
word was not censored on me so like it's
like quotable lyrically okay that's a
good argument though right there yeah
and Snoop Dogg likes to say other n
words like nephew all the time nizzle
could have met nephew too like I don't
know I don't know he does say nephew
yeah all the time
well Anthony what do you think well
Anthony owner of a business what do you
think what speak on this I mean I've
already said what I said Goldberg had
her back yeah yeah Whoopi Goldberg said
it's hard it's too hard to keep up see
we got Whoopi Charlemagne not fair
because like if she had said that 10
years ago or like 20 years ago also I
mean the goal post always moving and
she'd been doing it for 20 years and
this is funny she also cause controversy
last October when she referred to a
black reporter's Grand Mammy while on
the air okay that's bad so she is it
Grandma's Grandma they don't say Mammy
no more really really
is that a thing who doesn't she said
though no it sounds plantationy yeah
though not intentional I Now understand
how my comment was both insensitive and
hurtful I have apologized to Carmen Poe
the person she was talking to and you
know so just saying bro we're at the
point where you say Grand Mammy and it's
like yo that's [__] [__] up [__]
that's why is she from the south because
what if she refers to her Grandma's
grandmammy
oh I don't know do I just call my mom
mama I don't think a lot of things from
the south are being taken too well
anymore you can't even say things like
master bedroom anymore right oh yeah
what do they call it the big room I
don't even know
when they're doing the real estate tours
they don't call them Masters what do you
say
um something sweet or something they
don't yeah they don't say master bedroom
well they should for Asians because it
sounds like a karate master and we like
that yeah the Sensei we want the grand
master bedroom
suite the seafood sweet man quarter I
mean there was every everything is kind
of just being scrutinized it's it's a
hypersensitive time you know and it's
not one to I wouldn't be one to like be
like nah this is wrong or anything like
that because again these are during
times that affect like people were
people that was like maybe not
necessarily we were living you know what
I mean in that experience yeah but in
the if it was an Asian version I mean
yeah it to me this is a black
conversation a black topic right for me
I'm just like all I all I can see it as
is like someone who's a fan of the music
quoted their music that they listen to
for me I just take Charlemagne I take
Whoopi I use them as human shield they
said it and we move on yeah
but if it was an Asian one
I already don't think that we are at the
Forefront of getting our panties in the
bunch whenever Asian [__] goes down why
would you get your opinions in a bunch
well there's gonna be painful I got
boxers that's why but why is it gonna be
famous because they're smoother
is it it could Bunch up pretty easier is
it offensive when someone uh not Asian
is seeing that fast and furious song and
they're going I wonder if you know how
they need
that's authentically how they sound in
the song yeah huh that is how they're
not putting a voice on that's how they
sound anybody but white people sing
Charlie puth it's [__] racist
[Music]
foreign